ورينامي لف الانتخابات الامريكيه لكن من
زاويه مختلفه المشاهير ايضا لاعبون في
الانتخابات وبما انه حديث الساعه الى
الماسك صاحب المزاج المتقلب دعا صراحه
الناخبين لدعم المرشحين الجمهوريين ماسك
عاده وغرد قائلا انه منفتح على فكره
التصويت للديمقراطيين مره اخرى في
المستقبل وانه تاريخيا كان مستقلا وسوط
لديمقراطيين لكن ربما ما غير رايه هو
مصلحته الاقتصاديه فقد عبر عن دعمه
للجمهوريين سابقا بعد اقتراح الديمقراطيين
بفرد ضرائب على الملياردات ولا ننسى طبعا
الخلافات العلميه مع رئيس
ليس فقط مصر يا نادين وهو الذي يخضع ب14
مليون متابع على تويتر من يعلن توجهه
السياسي بالفعل تتسارقها اصحاب المال
والمشاهير ممثلين مغنيين رياضيين قرروا
الانخراط بشكل واضح في المشهد السياسي
الامريكي تشير دراسات لان هناك تاثير كبير
للمشاهير ليس فقط جهه النزول للصناديق
الاقتراع بل لتغيير ارائهم في احيان اخرى
واختيار مرشح بعينيه فمثلا وحسب ارقام
الانتخابات التمهيديه لحزب الديمقراطي عام
2008 فان حماس المذيعه الشهيره اوبرا
وينفي باراك اوباما حينها منحه نحو مليون
صوت اضافي للعلاء معه مزيد من التفاصيل
لكل نجم ومشهور اولويات يراها في مرشحه او
الجهه التي يدعمها ويرى انه اكثر قدره على
تحقيقها مثل اهداف القضايا البيئيه وسياسه
حمل السلاح مثلا والاجهاض كان الممثل
والمغني جون ليجند الفائز بجائزه ايجوت
صريحا على حسابه على تويتر لدعم العديد من
المرشحين الديمقراطيين قبل انتخابات
التجديد النصفيه
صاحب شخصيه اند مان او الرجل الشهيره اعلن
مشاركته في حمله تبرعات لصالح مرشح
ديمقراطيه الاعلاميه الشهيره
دخلت غرفه دردشه على موقع الديمقراطيه
السياسي لتشجع سكان ولايه جورجيا على
دعمها وعلى الجانب الاخر في عالم المشاهير
المغني كيدروك يعلن دعمه للجمهوريين دائما
وايضا المعلق السياسي الشهير نيك ادمز كتب
تغريده مرفقه بصوره الرئيس الساب ترامب
داعيا للتصويت للجمهوريين لانقاذ امريكا
حسب قوله ايضا يدعم معسكر الجمهوريين نجوم
اظهر دعمهم سابقا لترامب مثل ستايسي دهش
وكريستي الي بالاضافه الى والد النجمه
انجلينا جولي الممثل جون بويت لكن دائما
يقال بوليود في صف الديمقراطيه
[موسيقى]
حاجات المايك
منور
في الانتخابات كيف يغيرون
اهل السلطه في ازمه ثقه بين السياسيين
التقليديين
وناس من هون بيلجاوا المرشحين للانتخابات
للتاثير على حملاتهم بهدف اولا جمع
التبرعات
ثانيا الاصوات
الاعلامي بحملات الانتخابيه والاهتمام
فيهم والتركيز عليهم
والاهم توسيع الش العمري اللي عاده ما
بتهتم بالسياسه لا يجذبوهم وقت اللي رئيس
بايرن بالانوغريشن بحفل التنصيب عنده ليه
دجاجه وجيلو وكيتي باري بيكون عارف شو عم
بيعمل يعني عم يجذب من لا يهتم بالسياسي
اليه اضيف الى ذلك الناس انتخبت
فولدومير زينسكي كريم ممثل وفكاهه
رونالدو
وغير وغير وغير اذا تداخل عالم السياسي
والفن والشهره مش شديد وبداي بيغذوا بعضهم
من بعض
المشاهير تستفيد من عالم السياسي من حيث
النفوس
والبرستيج اللي ما بيعطيني اياه بس الفن
والرجال وسيدات السياسي بيستفيدوا طيب
يوصلوا لشريحه اكبر ويزيدوا اهتمام
الاعلام
والتواصل اليوم التويتر تحول الى احدى
وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه انصحت تعبير الى
اي حد اليوم صار حجم تاثيره اكبر من سي ان
ان مثلا فوكس نيوز
ما في شك انه تويتر هو حكينا عنه قبل
كوميوريتي هايبر هو هو برلمان الشعب على
امتداد العالم وهو منه بس امريكي امريكي
اليوم لانه في انتخابات نصفين اليوم لانه
طبعا تاثيره كثير كبير بالانتخابات وكان
يعني الدخول الى ماسك على يعني تزكيه
ترشيح للجمهوريين مهمه بوقت كان دقيق قال
انا بصور جمهوري بس بما انه الرئيس
الديمقراطي ادعو الى كونجرس وسنه
تويتر امبارح حاطط ماسك انه انا قلت تايم
هاي يعني باعلى ايام وبس ما حطلنا كيف
اعلى تفاعل واعلى مشاركه فيه عنده همم
الانقاذ تويتر
جزء كبير منها مساله الاشراف على المحتوى
وتنظيم اللي بنسميه كونتنت مودريشن مهمه
لو نحاول ان نفهم عقليه المشاهير في دعم
الانتخابات ودعم الناخبين في هذه
الانتخابات يعني اوبرا وين فري كانت
وتمسكت بدعم اوباما والديمقراطيه حتى
اليوم اليوم شهدنا انه ماسك غير توجهه
للجمهوريه كيف يمكن فهم عقليه المشاهير في
الدعم اولا في مصالح
والمشاهير اذكياء مثل السياسيين بيشوفوا
وين مصلحتهم بس اوقات ما في مصالح في
مبادئ في كثير من المشاهير همم دعم
ومرشحين للانتخابات اقتناءا فعلا منهم
بانه هل مرشح يمثل قيامهم ومبادهم
ومبادئهم ورغبتهم بالتغيير شوفناها وقت
انتخاب الرئيس جوبادل الدعوه للانتخابات
بس روحي بتاثر على نتائج الانتخابات بيكون
اذا صوت كثير ناس بيجيبوا اكس واذا ما صوت
الناس بجيبه واهي هيك
اللي عم تحكيها هلا انا ما بعرف بالقانون
ما بدي احكي بالقانون بس باخلاقيات
المواطنه هل مقبول لشخص مؤثر في مجال عمله
ان يتحول الى شخص مؤثر في مجال سياسه بلده
اكيد
مشهور ولا انسان عادي هلا في سريه التصويت
والاقتراع عاده يفضل بالقوانين انك ما
تتصوري بداخل العازل الانتخابي وقالت
تجاهر بمن انتخبت في واجب تحفظ لدى الرجال
وسيدات للعام وندى المشاهير بس كيتي بيري
اليوم على بكره مصوره انه صوت يتلكروز
لكاليفورنيا وحتى صورتها ايفوته وصورته
مشاهير م- ما في يعني يحق للمشاهير ما لا
يحق لغيرهم وفي بعض الاحيان
الحظ في القوانين والنظم
وبتثلجم بتلجم السياسيين اكثر وتحاسبهم
اكثر مما تلجم المشاهير وقت الجمهور